I want to welcome everybody back to this
afternoon session my name is Tanya domi
and I am an adjunct professor affiliate
with the human institute i have taught
on the region of the former Soviet Union
but indeed this is not my specialty so I
apologize in advance if I make any
mistakes in pronunciation I am a media
expert and have worked in the region not
in Ukraine I have worked in Armenian
Georgia I might add that I teach a human
rights course at harriman and have been
hosting all year a speaker series on
LGBT Human Rights emerging in the
Balkans let me just say a couple of
things about the media environment in
Ukraine it's fraught with all kinds of
challenges lots of oppression impunity I
think is a good character a good word to
describe how Ukrainian officials in this
state has actively oppressed reporters
media houses outlets using tax police
straight out violence criminalizing
defamation doing the reverse of
progressive liberalism across the globe
Ukraine is going in the opposite
direction of course nothing really
should Shura can be said about the fact
that the former president has been let
off the hook in terms of his own
personal role in the execution of mr.
Georgie go God said and I remember his
murder in two thousand I had just left
left the Balkans at that time it was at
absolutely shocking the fact that the
case is still being litigated is indeed
evidence of impunity at work I might add
to and would be remiss if I did not
point out that there's been a wave of
anti-gay violence in the region to wit
ol inna shevchenko is just the latest in
evidence of that of a Prussian she was
arrested and tried in December for
organizing a protest without first
notifying city authorities I met Elena
in December at the UN and did an
interview of her at that time I think
she and all of her colleagues represent
some of the bravest people right now
attempting to assert their human rights
and their ability to freedom and freedom
of expression I think that their example
is is is a good one in terms of what is
current on the ground facing so many
people throughout the former Soviet
Union and indeed also in in the former
Yugoslavia the idea that people are
outside somehow the Western norm the
fact that states like Ukraine and Russia
and other states in the region
pejoratives and call them EU values the
fact that they ignore rulings by the
European Court of Human Rights with
impunity is a real testament to those
these people they're very inspirational
I understand what it's like to fight
outside what is conventionally
acceptable and for those who stand up
and confront the state this is now in
the 21st century the new the new
movement for Human Rights which is being
fought in Ukraine and in the region so
it is my pleasure to and that is part of
our discourse today and I wanted to make
a point on that so this panel is media
discourse ideology and discrimination
and we're going to have a thorough
examination here the Ukrainian media and
looking at the various representations
of language historical memory ethnicity
race and sexual orientation I regret
that I haven't been able to read the
papers in advance but I do look forward
to hearing our colleagues speak and make
their presentation I want to enter
introduce them very quickly Nicholas
Burns on is the coordinator for the
Center for European studies at Lund
University and a PhD student in eastern
and central european studies he's going
to present a case study maximum boot
Kevin who is from no borders an NGO
where he is currently the co coordinator
of the Social Action Center you can read
his bio he's obviously very experienced
in the field of media he is going to
give us a presentation on xenophobia the
phantom menace and proactive other how
Ukrainian media tend to present migrants
in the LGBT community and I'm delighted
that we are joined by vola mayor kulik
who is with the national academy of
sciences at ukraine and harvard
university he's going to discuss
languages in New York your crane ian
media regulations markets in ideology
Lula mayor is quite accomplished he's
the head research fellow at the
Institute of political and ethnic
studies national academy of sciences of
ukraine
and he's currently the petrol yeah siq
distinguished research fellow at the
harvard ukrainian research institute so
without further ado who would like to
begin okay Nicholas okay please take the
floor okay and so within this panel on
that ideological dimensions of Ukrainian
media discourse I was invited to speak
about how the Ukrainian media deals with
issues of historical memory thank you
for the invitation and I have earlier
done some work on language and identity
in Ukraine mixed languages and much of
it based on on mass media material and
as for the coverage of historical memory
in Ukrainian mass media this is of
course a huge and dynamic topic and it
confronts no less ideological diversity
and complexity then then you can find in
other fields of Ukrainian memory
discourse so I will limit this
discussion 22 news media and take my
examples from newspapers which is the
genre I have mostly worked with and so I
will try to give a quick quick view on
on the medium medium in memory
discourses on the national level firstly
which are the key memory topics and the
most important explicit ideological
positions and that shape discursive
space and i will then also try to
provide most of my empirical examples
from a case study i made on how a
multicultural historical past is is
dealt with in local ukrainian language
newspapers in Chernivtsi in ukrainian
bucovina
so the am here was to study how the
media coverage of Genesis 600 univer
anniversary in 2008 dealt with the
multi-ethnic past of this former
Austrian and Romanian city and with a
presently mostly absent ethnic groups
that once took part in building the city
such as juice Germans poles and so on
and so this might illustrate how some
general features of Ukrainian media
discourse in memory plays out in a local
field and but it also might offer
insights into her media works with
historical pasts that are at least
partly different from the most usually
studied battlefields of partisan
discourses what is a Ukrainian
nationalist at the nationalist versus
here innocent eastern slavic or
neo-soviet so get one and then I will
conclude bah bah bah shortly taking a
quick look of at the modes of
remembering that can be identified in
memory work in Ukrainian news media and
so use media unlike other media angles
like film literature music is considered
by several researchers to be
understanding as sources for for memory
status and this is particularly so in
post-soviet memory studies this might be
surprising since media as volodymyr
kulick Argus mediates the communication
for the academic producers with the
general population and the so for people
of all ages EDI argues that journalistic
accounts of the past can have wide
implications for collective memory and
might affect how collective identities
and societal cohesion are informed by
reflections on the past especially this
might be so when society is in a state
of flux and is perceived to lack
stability and common ground and where
there is no clear hegemonic v1 on
certain issue
and often there must be some kind of
reason for for for the media to write
about historical events rarely the
publication is not soft and a
publication is triggered by the mayor
wish of an author to to reflect on the
past so often media memory work starts
somewhere else in politics for example
with supporting or challenging dominant
discourses or by the publication of
artistic academic books the making of
the film on historical subject and so on
which tank can be remedial eyes and
adjusted in various way bye-bye news
media and we have exceptions of course
in specialized additions or additions to
to some newspaper or new sites like
service to reach no problem but it's the
original product Oh cranes can put up
the websites for example one can find
extensive articles on subjects that are
not maybe so much discussed at the very
moment elsewhere and so media is not a
primary producer but memories in use
media are not only remediated from other
domains but they are shaped all sober
journalistic and editorial processes of
selection and interpretation and some
actress might have their views had more
easily than others obviously and so if
media is not the primary producer of
historical memory memory discourse then
is it's no surprise that media is
comprised of what is already out there
in the society to purchase so the
archive of me realized memories is
obviously huge with all the diversity of
memories ranging from personal memories
of protagonists appearing in the media
collective memories of smaller scale
social units families individual
neighborhoods local sports team to
memories that are connected to larger
identity narratives about well wider
social units pertaining to region a city
or an ethnic group a nation or imagined
super national community like the
eastern slavic one for example what do
europeans one
and as for the wider national relatives
memory media lized memory in Ukraine
often boils down to larger themes and
frameworks that I perceived to have the
most salience in the country and most
importantly to disputed issues that of
the defining memory memory conflicts so
to speak and it is often said that on
the national level historical memory in
Ukraine could be characterized as
divisive and even polarized so this
reflects the diversity of social a
cultural and political assailant salient
as the cultural and regional identities
and the historical memories that
challenge your support them and so
collective memory in any country of
course isn't constantly evolving
occurrence there might be difference
here between say a post-soviet post
colonial society such as the Ukrainian
and some say more established nation
states such as Sweden so in Sweden even
when we have conflicting positions on
some salient historical topics there is
a general agreement on on which is the
community that is viewed as the subject
of this memory so the polarization in
Ukrainian memory debates to some extent
might reflect the lack of such a subject
the main partisan narratives consist as
you as you know and researchers might
use different terms of one narrative
that could be described as a Ukrainian
nationalist and the Soviet and a
competing one that is often called say
East Slavic or neo-soviet maybe these
narratives do not of course only involve
historical memory but are often tied to
specific use on other controversial
subjects such as language and they are
of course tied to competing political
agendas parties organizations that
support or exploit them for various
purposes and so there are two
overarching highly symbolically charged
and in terms of content very large
ideological packages that are regularly
played out in the ukrainian news media
and then among the most sensitive and
regularly featured topics this
narratives conflict about our the
holodomor the mass famine from the early
1930s of course Second World War various
topics their latest years most notably
OPA but it there can be references to 22
other symbolically charged themes that
might be attributed to this larger
narratives and other conflicting
historical memory is organized into
ethnic cultural narratives are sometimes
reflected in newspaper and electronic
media on the national level sometimes
Ukrainian polish-english Galicia
villania Crimea with this intersecting
Ukrainian Russian taught our memories
rarely in the national press you can see
Ukrainian Romanian memory topics then
you have Ukrainian Jewish memories and
sometimes you can say that the toxic
memories from World War 2 that partly
are outside the framework of competing
those competing discourses but tend to
be part of a larger international memory
discourse there might be other recurring
themes that might have have a different
logics for example conflicts of
historical preservation of a certain
built urban heritage for example where
the struggle often is portrayed as being
between social movements and activists
arguing for preservation and and
financial interests within various roles
roles being awarded to to civil servants
we have recently we had example of
andrieski was releasing in Kiev in this
regard in Chattanooga see there has been
such discussions on the building of a
new scene amount or on the place of the
Jewish temple and so the relevant
division here is not ethnic cultural but
rather between various perspectives and
priorities and in some cases one could
put it in the old 19th century Russian
terms such as oopsie oopsie versus
intelligent some degree
and as for charity I recently took part
in a book project at our Center and
learned about multicultural memories in
Eastern and Central European cities
cities that have gone through
fundamentalist on demographic changes in
the indeed 20th century such as Genuity
review virat suave casino etc and so how
does the present majority population of
sachet cities remember the old ethnic
cultural diversity from the time before
population transfers Exodus a genocide
so I then wrote the chapter on the
coverage of multicultural memories in
about channel it sees 600th anniversary
in 2008 in in five ukrainian language
newspapers and the newspapers include
melody Bukovina Bukovina trois doba
journey see I can talk a bit more about
that in the question times someone is
interested and there are a number of
reasons why this research might be of
interest to this panel firstly it is a
case study of memory work in local media
which is an even more understudied
aspect of memory discourses in the in
Ukraine and secondly this mythologized
multi-ethnic and multilingual passed off
of opportunity and Bukovina makes it
possible to study multicultural memory
and a topic partly outside the
bipartisan discourse is so to speak
thirdly memory culture in in in bucovina
is more ambivalent and a bit more
relaxed in in comparison with memory
culture in neighbouring kaliesha or
would say national conflicts between
between the parties and memory
discourses and for example as for the
general setting the urban taphonomy
ingenuity has been only recently only
partially d server tised and other
narrative has rather been added to the
to the urban symbol symbolic landscape
for example ukrainian national
liberation relative as well as street
names and monuments devoted to to to the
city's multi ethnic heritage and the
region's austrian and romanian past so
there is an ambivalence
existence and avoidance of conflicts
between different narratives that makes
the city closer to citizens and to
Ukraine maybe then in two for example
view so often the relations between the
narratives are characterized not by
continuity or reinterpretation but not
by distinct break they'd rather just
shared the same space so they add that
narrative story the existing ones so
narrative diversity is recognized but
not problematized and and we end the
conflict is rather avoided and sometimes
you can detect the lack of
conceptualization is deliberate could
give you some example of that and I can
also see that that and this reoccurs in
the media coverage of of the corpus I
studied fourthly prosthetic memories
shaped by stories in news media can be
important for those who have no personal
memories of the existing past and the
parents and grandparents of the great
majority of city dwellers ingenuity did
not live in the city in 1940 so there
are not many people left with their own
memory of pre-war times and many people
with potential post memories are do not
live in the city anymore so this is the
case where media lized memory my time
might be quite important and fifthly the
media discourse provide insights into
local ideas and cultural diversity on
those specific tropes saying local
political medial and academic narratives
and ethnic relations this is frequently
called the buca winscott all around
lists the bucatini intolerance which you
can hear everywhere in the media well if
from a multitude of actors so it points
to the harmonious relations between
large number of ethnic and religious
groups and remembers the Austrian times
as a golden age for the city and tries
to connect this to the city notions on
about the city's European us so it's
kind of conservative multiculturalism
that does not include say gay rights or
feminist positions
and so it's a tolerance that that
recognizes diversity and celebrates
diversity but there is no real discourse
on power rights come on power relations
for example and so one can ask them and
if this anniversary did the trigger your
memory discourses in local newspapers on
the multi multi ethnic past in the city
and on the one hand it did there were
quite a few historical representations
of the Austrian period for example
enough the ethnic groups that inhabited
the city earlier it was quotes from
official speeches a few lengths here
essays and in the actual reporting from
the festivities and the old diversity is
mentioned in connection with the opening
of new monuments presentation of books
german english language writers for
example stories about some visitors to
the city the architecture for example
from Austrian times and on the other
hand with the exception of some printed
speeches of politicians and a few more
extensive stories there were little
reflection and little interpretation of
what the past might mean for
contemporary city dwellers so there is
there was no scent there was no single
article or news item that discussed the
actual fate of the earlier inhabitants
so it is quite clear that local media
did not operate in the mode of say
raising consciousness or drawing moral
lessons that for example you can find in
st. Swedish media although always often
quite clumsy and they rather sort out
another form of usual usable pathogenic
see the multi-ethnic past was not
ignored but rather local minima like
actors seems to regard the multi-ethnic
past as an asset rather than a challenge
so it's an asset for City branding it's
an asset for commercial use is an asset
for political use and the relations
between the present post-soviet normalcy
of the city and components of its owner
multi-ethnic parts are also seldom
problematized
so the festivities showcased the
presence it is ethnic diversity by
pointing to the open and tolerant
cooperation of distinct say Ukrainian
Romanian Polish Jewish communities
native to book a winner but the near
exclusive exiles status of for example
poles and induce was not was alluded to
it rather than being explained to the
readers so perhaps one might argue that
if thats a striking feature of how
memory is operationalized in media disco
series is the absent absence of what
sociologists and media and memory
scholar the areola calls the politics of
regret this is of course an umbrella
term for for various practices such as
public apologies the work of truth
Commission's reparation and criminal
prosecution that are united by a
perceived need to confront toxic
legacies of the past so the politics of
regret focuses on toxic issues like
crimes against humanity genocides
legacies of totalitarian regimes
persecution of minorities and so on so
in this did this is drawn upon also as a
source of modern political
legitimization only one does not point
to the good past the the glory full past
but to the painful past and the trouble
troubles or memories so it's a
collective memories that that is done
disgusted by itself and put emphasis on
the learning relation to lessons of
history rather than celebrating morally
uplifting continuities ingenuity to
achieve a usual past it seems that one
rather looks for positive continuities
one picks up the elements that can be
used for community building a city
branding today this is perhaps what
Connerton call the type of forgetting
that is constitutive for the shaping of
the new identity and you can also say
that it builds on earlier Soviet
elements to Tucson to some extent
and this done taught me that memory
discourse in Ukrainian news media in
general is dominated by by glorious and
heroic versions of the past there's at
least it must as much focus on suffering
and there is more of a focus on one's
own suffering rather than on the wrongs
one might have done to others so on the
national level the common mode in in
explicit emotionally charged partisan
discourses is that someone else should
be regretful the opposite the opposite
camp it can be up against the community
with whatever but but they should regret
themselves now the point here is not
that everyone should readily embrace
Hegelian mission to reach the final
stage of historical consciousness is
something like that i mean the merits of
politics of regret are not
straightforward but debatable and for
example in terms of community cohesion
there are also many ways in a country
like sweden where you can point to the
existence of this this large mode of
remembering like regret there are
thousands of ways for for politicians
and leading actors to escape
responsibility so this is not a
normative argument is a rubber weight of
pointing to a specific feature of memory
discourses here and which perhaps can be
discussed later thank
you